hello to all allow me to
take this opportunity to
welcome president
fender flaiano sold at luxembourg
it is a great honor for our country
also for me to receive you my
country has always been a faithful ally of
the european commission  is also a
defender of the European project and of the
Community method which consists
precisely in also taking into
consideration the specificities of each
Member State,
whatever its size 6 convinced
that we can also continue on
this path with your committee which
is not only the guardian
treaties but also that of the
Community method during our interview
we had a wide range of
issues that we discussed
allow me to focus on two
healthy subjects in more detail the
first which is that of climate policy
and that  also of the
multiannual financial framework
for climate policy
our gra  nd duchy welcomes the adoption of the
green pact and also
rightly welcomes the ambition sought with
the objective of climate neutrality
of our union by 2050 the transition
to a carbon neutral economy
by 2050 is not  only a
constraint but also presents a number
of opportunities and we too often forget
to also talk about the opportunities
presented by this transition
I regret that for some this
tendency to want to transform these
discussions just on leproux the
clear content Luxembourg remains  opinion that
nuclear is not a solution to
climate change and that it is an
energy source that is insecure
unsustainable and the costs at 6 thousand are
often also underestimated and that is
why we consider it essential  to be
able to have a 100%
la bhl scenario as we also discussed
during the last European Council
together in order to better be able to see
the
benefits of such a scenario are also calculated in application  he strategy with regard
to the multiannual financial framework,
our country was from the outset in
favor of the
commission's initial proposal and will also continue to plead
for adequate volumes and
better consideration
of future policies such as  the climate digital
and research without an
ambitious modern European budget and reforming the
single market will remain fragmented will not be able to
finance said cobourne to
political priorities and I must tell you that the
current proposals are
simply not realistic
they are not realistic  are not
ambitious and are not compatible
with the common political agenda that we
are given as a european union
i was at the various meetings in
bratislava where it was said that we must do
more for migration i was at
goeteborg we said that we had to do
more for the social I was in rome when
we said that we are moreover more
for young people I was so many
meeting we said to ourselves that we have to
do more but once that if we
decide to want to do more we must
also give the means to do more
and allow me too to repeat what
I have already said even  if i am one of the
few to say so as head of
government or heads of state that to
think that a drastic reduction of 2
billion in the european public administration
is not simply not
acceptable for luxembourg cannot
don't expect high
quality service give yourself an ambitious agenda
by telling yourself that we will do it with no one
else so it's not possible
saddens us and rosny desroches 2010
our commission bring political ground
priority gold for any size fort knox in
box inc
gold that you go three minutes to the
final like diane english in president
president in flight trainer
working conditions in the mines breath and
reproductive froch not
as long as prime minister it goes it comes
if a bank makes  offers i
sponsor charlie sheen m fans who is
strong this anal probe the good news is going to
be a weekend world affirms yarn
jiabao khalid wichter luxemburg place at the
trap works we won 4 is
now the luxe range in black list
8pm at the  European antiquity 2010
need file and suddenly we have there a
board the hymn originally to oujda with the
design that mu and five medals
with lisa roig date under zine and
fine in orthez luxemburg ch tactile full
ring facing  robin grossmann ndiaye
chistophe ashmeade stylophone
nationality and not by the sq
we have a formula 1 the status quo ante and
post natal in euro facing canada
baguette sandwich looks girls therefore
celebrated this title contrary to what is
described a climate sell the climate
shoot fighter planes everything if not the best
dunkeur pinguins mind compliments the
same respects luxembourg fire jean
charest whose meetings scooter in front of
phil cox box finances a chômiste fair
is the fi climate
nancier honey for petzi neutral climate al zain
viên d'influx of so-called
europe investments and at baxter autism strategy
at lannepax to the strategies of ladies
planet but be sure that they pts a
resource and acid a dwarf planet
technology investment and export from
since its  used wonderfully morgue and with
the help of a stock crane were of a
present restitution he remained
stationed at production working in so
and how do you know about his own words
of india login audineau thus invested
horrible esteem after i  trains
kids brittany france her vaccines
lifeline shaft moving methanal from ag
insurance brittany years lives nahuda
endpoint fang russian for my daughter and i
'll tell you who and vattenfall there was nor that
she had planned
european along a street of a  city
e mench
v is points out trader a lette
from ex esteem on a date at 2009 rusti
fund nba scouts from a luxem
ourg park positions dickens clapt
n paul browne gold
there is political declaration of
political cohesion to the island ja in
political farce before being betrayed esteem uwe
the background music of european union
d'azur is son had aimed as a
film is enormous said victor of the
personal linked data  for to gander but
how do you do to water and close
a commission of 4 million the number
of these as it is necessary to buy a
life to invest and terrorist attacks
even if it means halo wars actions quick
was of the age indicated ms. michaud bingo
our right  in rabat
what you need and buildings process for
government a view to go to be you we
know it because actors
not always better normal Libyan narrate
a fluo evening
just to have a delay hair not
[Music]
there is a lot to you  integrate researcher
guillaume brossard intensity 110
communicative gaiety
[Music]
but at lens we roll in place
lighthouse measures of lighning invested kaput
a syndrome 10 to regulate this type of
wholesale are bought european  ne weekend ue
grishin launches m and buy below
like a destruction we at opinion way
problem of signatures at pij commer cials
will be put on standby
billions invested and regions
added duncan concrete stif art of
like a beacon turtle in this  loudmouth
public opinion is the city where i had no
nuclear accident
after the mysterious island as in a
state drives the heart of glass by
franz ludwig m and of war is in crisis
huge leaflets what the once
complicated  says or m that is going to
be originally in n2 what i loan via
iphone men and animals are basically
what i advocate to decrease
newspapers earn a seat which is hard on the
foot for us we have large sums
[Laughs]